[Music]
let's go out to Karina in Columbus Ohio
what's up
Karina hello
hello what's up how are you um I'm great
thank you for uh talking to me I really
appreciate it of course thanks for
calling what's up um I have lost a lot
of weight this year how much and about
65 lbs
whoa well I still have a fair amount to
lose but I'm uhuh we're not blown by
that yeah so dude that's my
daughter yeah and I carry my daughter
around through New York City a few weeks
ago and she got very very heavy yeah
you've lost my child dude
congratulations that's amazing how have
you done it uh I am uh taking shots okay
and and Di and I've started to move a
little bit more good for you I'm proud
of you what's your goal how far how far
do you want to go I I really need to
lose at least 100 pounds okay 100 pounds
total or 100 more just 100 total and
really according to the charts it should
be 150 but if I can get 100 off it's you
know it's lifechanging really for me I'm
telling you 65 is lifechanging you got
35 to go you'll be there in no time
congratulations so proud of you when you
add movement to this obviously with your
doctor when you add movement to this oh
it's going toel dude I'm so proud of you
it's awesome all right so what's up well
I'm concerned because I can't see it
okay I've um and I'm worried if I can't
figure out how to see the weight loss
that I'm going to gain the weight
back because that's my my hu my biggest
fear is that I gain the way back okay so
when you say you can't see it is it
objective or is it um body
dysmorphic I'm not sure yeah I said that
as dorky as I could have so objective
like when you see people you haven't
seen in a few weeks or you see your
doctor are they just like oh my gosh and
you're just like y' are crazy
or um did you have so much to lose that
65 lbs is not even halfway to the like
you see what I'm saying like you have a
long long way to go it really took 40
lbs or so for people started to see and
like at the 50 lb Mark now people are
saying you know they're they're noticing
okay but I've once I started looking at
this I've noticed like I have I don't
look at myself in the mirror I Look to
make sure I'm clean or I don't have
wrinkles but I have no full body mirrors
in my house I don't look at me because I
don't like how I look I guess there you
go and like if I go try clothes on the
other day I need new clothes I had
everything from an extra large to a 4X
cuz I hadn't I couldn't look at the
clothes and see that fits my body where
did you end up at did you end up with uh
downsizes yeah of course you did because
you lost 65 pounds you lost my
child right but I hold up a Forex and
I'm like well maybe that fits well yeah
you know and I'm just really really
afraid I'll gain the weight back cuz
it's I'm taking the shots which help
sure but it's hard work yeah it is all
right so here here's what I think here's
what I think tell me if I'm crazy can
can we just speak like just direct
friend to friend brother to sister yes
all right yes I
think you can see
it I think you thought it would feel
differently H I think you thought losing
65 lbs well on your way to 100
100 which is
unbelievable that's amazing and if your
doctor has said hey 150 would be great
my 13-year-old son is humongous he's
140 I could carry him on my back not
very
far so the thought of losing the
entirety of my 13-year-old my eighth
grade son who by all metrics is
humongous that's amazing
and it is removing a barrier between you
and the
world and in some way that barrier kept
you safe or kept you hidden or kept
you some space between you and the
world and there's this there's a lie
that says when we lose that we're
suddenly gonna if we get a million
dollars suddenly we're gonna if I get
that car suddenly we're gonna if I lose
this weight suddenly I'm
gonna and you go to the mirror and you
look just at your face because you don't
have a full body mirror and you thought
it would feel different what do you
think well I do agree I I feel invisible
A lot of the time because of my weight
you know you want to be invisible that's
right and there's a certain level of
comfort in that of course yeah and that
and that Comfort kills you right yeah
yeah but
um yeah I guess I I thought I would be
happier that's it right there you know I
I thought
I mean I guess happier maybe why
why what happened to Karina that Karina
thinks she's just a piece of
crap I think you know everything goes
back to when you're young you know I had
I came from a fairly religious family
and I ended up getting pregnant at 15
and I had my son okay and I did not not
get married and I did not give him away
and I did not have an abortion did that
cost you
everything pretty much yeah most of my
family disowned me yeah so you know you
figured out at 15 that love was for the
people who were closest to you love for
your tribe love for your family was
contingent yeah and I figured out I was
not going to be loved and that's pretty
much carried through my entire adult
life well once you once once you in your
15-year-old mind thought that and you
had some pretty compelling
evidence you went looking for that
everywhere
right every single place you could find
proofed that you weren't worth being
loved you went and found
it this is true and I don't we don't
trust 15y olds to
drive right because they're crazy
they're not allowed to buy beer or guns
or go to the milit right because they're
and
your 15-year-old also got a really clear
glimpse of some harsh
reality you are only lovable if you do
the right thing otherwise Love's
off right and that wasn't that wasn't
theory for you that was
real and it made me very angry for a
very long time you should
be but um you should
be you know the number of parents I've
sat with when their kid gets pregnant in
colleges
and they come to me and they say '
whatat do I do what do I
say and I ask them you remember when you
found out you were pregnant and you had
a baby coming and you remember holding
that baby the first time and they always
smile and I say don't take that from
that kid 15's really young that's hard
15's hard 18 19 20 it's a little bit
different but 15 is
tough yeah but I've had Parents call me
and say hey we went with this isn't the
picture we had for you but we're about
to have a
baby and so they Circle the wagon even
tighter the wagon of Love they Circle
that connection even
Tighter and you didn't have that at 15
you were all by
yourself it was um it was not an easy
time no but no and how old are you now
57 okay
57 so for 42 years you've been carrying
this
around
yeah when are you going to let
Karina that 15-year-old Karina finally
drop her shoulders and go be
15 because she's still fighting for you
she's still hating for you she's still
angry for you she still doesn't look
beautiful to you she still remembers all
the
comments when you going to let her
go I don't know CU my I've tried to work
on my internal messaging to
myself and it's still fairly negative
yeah and I'm I I don't know how to fix
that per here's what we're going to do
we are going to
learn to be objective about feelings and
this is a crappy awful hard thing to do
okay but I promise you and I promise
because I've experienced it myself
personally you can change this
okay a unless your doctor says I'm wrong
right your doctor would know like
pathologies your doctor would know some
mental health challenges your doctor
would know this kind of stuff more than
me but I would recommend you getting a
mirror one of those $10 mirrors that's
full
length because here's what you're doing
you're avoiding you every
day
and I want you to head directly into
that
discomfort because Karina is worth being
L does Karina have a lot of weight to
lose and some health challenges you're
dang right she does and I'm not one of
these like body positivity like you're
that's not true and Karina's worth being
loved and Karina's worth taking care of
herself right and clearly you know this
because you've made
incredible inspirational progress in
change
but you can't tell me I don't see it and
at the same time avoid every mirror that
you come
across there's going to be some
recalibration you pick up a 4X and
you're like oh I think this is it and
then suddenly you end up in a 1X and
you're like whoa that's
normal that's like me getting in my old
farm truck and then getting in like a
newer car like I you know hit the gas
too fast and I hit the brake too hard
like I got to adjust to this new thing
right this new vehicle I'm in that's
okay that's part of it but I want you to
get a journal and I want you to keep
every time you think the words I'm gross
or I'm not making any
progress or I'm not
happy I want you to write those things
down and I want you to demand evidence
from
them because objectively what you're
telling me they're not
true or if you're not happy ask yourself
what could I do right now to increase
some of the some of the joy in my life
go for a walk go watch a sunset call my
kid go hang out call my girlfriends go
hang out what would that
be I ask you Karina what brings you
Joy um really BR you said you know I
talk to my son I talk to my friends I'm
I'm very fortunate I have friendships
that are 30 40 years
amazing um do they know do they truly
know that
Karina just is grossed out by
Karina they don't know that it's time to
bring no it's time to bring him in bring
him in yeah bring him in and I want you
to tell them this y'all know I've lost a
bunch of weight and I'm I've got another
100 pounds to go I'm going for another
90 pounds to
go but that's secondary
too I've got to reckon with and begin to
become friends with Karina again I'm
going to stop living a life where I
avoid
myself
will you guys walk alongside me as I
change my internal dialogue to
myself and I guarantee you they will God
I would be in honor if one of my friends
asked me to do
that oh they absolutely would I I'm very
blessed with some amazing friends that
is a like um in a strange way I'm asking
you to get a full length mirror and look
at yourself and make and put your hand
on your chest when you start to feel
that uh or that uh or
whatever I've lost 65
PBS I'm going to have five more down in
the next two weeks I'm going to whatever
whatever pace you're
on I want you to feel that objective
this this isn't working it's I'm not
doing anything is that true no
objectively it's false it's not true and
similarly I want you to telling your
friends over a regular cup of coffee
like Hey we're going to get together
once a week and if they're not in the
same Community we're going to do a zoom
call once a week I want you to hold up a
mirror relationally
emotionally hey guys I lost another
three pounds this week and I feel
disgusting I want you to say those words
out loud to the people who love you and
your
friends because you might not trust
Karina but you trust them do you yes
okay so for a season we're going to
start Outsourcing some of the truth
because we can't see it that's okay
we're recalibrating the whole system
kind of like when I get get my car and I
changed the tires on it and I put some
tough guy tires for hunting it felt like
my car was falling apart and one of my
buddies was like no this is how this
goes I had to Outsource that I didn't
know I just felt like the whole car was
falling apart because these tires were
big and stiff and he was like no no this
is exactly where it's supposed to be
it's
great we're gonna Outsource that for a
bit do you believe me when I tell you
I'm so freaking proud of you yes okay
are you like can we like can you just
drop shoulders and say 65 PBS is pretty
amazing you know I I was doing pretty I
was pretty happy with it and then I had
a conversation actually with my boss and
she has some very strong opinions about
people doing what I'm doing that it's
just
lazy and I hold on hold on hold on
dude yeah all right so here's a cool
thing that just
happened your boss opted
out yeah your boss doesn't get a vote
vot and remember that 15-year-old girl
who was looking for proof that she
wasn't
lovable and you've been looking for 42
years you in your head have this tiny
little narrative that's like you
shouldn't need to go to the
doctor you shouldn't need medicine you
shouldn't need shots you should just be
able to control
this yeah okay and your body is looking
desperately for somebody to validate
that you're a loser and you found
one and I want you to write that down
cuz that's objectively
false it's not
true Karina I've got two phds I do this
for a living sitting with hurting people
and I had to reach out and get
professional
help
okay
yeah I don't have one ounce of Shame you
know why because I couldn't do it by
myself
period I couldn't do it by myself cool
so you know what your boss did she opt
it
out oh you think I'm lazy
cool I'll never ever have this
conversation with you
again I want you to write it down I am
lazy for going to the doctor to get
support and help for
um my obesity
challenges is that true objectively no
it's not it's not it's not
true look around if we could all just
snap our fingers and just diet and
exercise we wouldn't have the crisis we
have it's a big
deal I'm so proud of you for doing what
you need to do and you know there's
going to be stages there's going to be
season as you mentioned like now I'm
just slowly getting into movement
great my guess is you're going to
accelerate things in a profound way and
you're going to begin to feel
differently because right now a lot of
this has just been thoughts and thoughts
and thoughts and thoughts and thoughts
and changing eating habits and shots and
now you're going to move into more body
transformation great
amazing slow and
steady there is a point Karina when you
have to stop thinking getting all the
thoughts in the right order you have to
start doing you've done step one you've
started working on step two and now
you're inching into step
three just keep taking steps inch by
inch by inch and I want you to let that
15-year-old girl go what happened to her
was wrong she was absolutely left on her
own in a blizzard with a baby and that
was
wrong
and that's not
everybody not everybody leaves a
15-year-old in the cold holding a baby
in fact most
don't so I want you to stop looking for
somebody to tell you what you're doing
is wrong somebody to tell you that
you're not enough and instead I want you
to get with your friends who love you
and to begin looking for people who see
you for who you are see how hard you're
working and who will cheer you on we're
done validating the bull craap stories
that were not
enough we're now validating the stories
that say wow look how hard you're
working keep going Karina I'm so proud
of
you